.
GARY TUCHMAN, CNN IN MOSCOW,
IDAHO.
>> OUR THANKS TO GARY FOR THAT.
>>> LET'S GO STRAIGHT TO CNN
SENIOR LEGAL ANALYST ELIE HONIG.
ELIE, WE ARE NOT JUST WATCHING
THIS CASE EVOLVE AND DEVELOP,
YOU KNOW, YOU TRIED NUMEROUS
MURDER CASES, BEEN INSIDE THE
LEGAL AND TECHNICAL PARTS OF
THIS PROCESS.
TELL ME WHAT YOU THINK AFTER
WATCHING GARY'S REPORT THERE
ABOUT HOW STRONG THE EVIDENCE
IS.
THE EVIDENCE, I GUESS
UNBEKNOWNST TO ALL OF US WHO
WERE FOLLOWING THIS CASE FOR
WEEKS HERE, WE DIDN'T REALIZE
THEY HAD EVIDENCE TO WORK OFF
OF, THESE INVESTIGATORS.
>> YEAH, JIM.
I THINK THE EVIDENCE IS
EXCEPTIONALLY STRONG.
LIKE YOU, I WAS EAGER TO SEE
THIS COMPLAINT BECAUSE ALL YOU
HAVE TO DO AS A PROSECUTOR IN A
COMPLAINT LIKE THIS IS ESTABLISH
PROBABLE CAUSE.
THAT'S A FAIRLY LOW STANDARD AND
SOMETIMES IN THESE COMPLAINTS
THAT'S REALLY ALL YOU WILL SEE,
BUT HERE THE PROSECUTORS WENT
WAY ABOVE THAT IN TERMS OF THE
EVIDENCE, THE DNA EVIDENCE IS
REALLY THE MOST IMPORTANT PIECE
AS GARY SAID.
THERE WAS A SAMPLE OF DNA
RECOVERED FROM A KNIFE SHEATH AT
THE SCENE THAT HAS BEEN MATCHED
TO THIS SUSPECT BY A 99.9998
PROBABILITY, SCIENTIFICALLY.
THAT IS VERY POWERFUL EVIDENCE.
ON TOP OF THAT, THE POLICE
REALLY DID AN EXCEPTIONAL JOB
ANALYZING HIS CELLPHONE RECORDS,
HIS AUTOMOBILE RECORDS, TO PLACE
HIM DEFINITIVELY AT THE SCENE OF
THE CRIME.
ON TOP OF THAT, WE KNOW THAT
THIS INDIVIDUAL SHOWED SOME
SIGNS THAT HE WAS TRYING TO
COVERUP HIS TRACKS AFTERWARDS.
WHEN YOU TAKE IT ALL TOGETHER,
JIM, IT IS REALLY A POWERFUL AND
I THINK COMPELLING SHOWING.
>> BUT, ELIE, ONE THING
INVESTIGATORS HAVE NOT RE-VIRGIN
REVEALED
TO THE PUBLIC IS MOTIVE.
>> YOU HAVE TO PROVE INTENT AS A
PROSECUTOR, MEANING THAT THE
PERSON INTENDED TO KILL.
YOU DO NOT HAVE TO PROVE LEGALLY
MOTIVE, WHICH IS WHY DID THE
PERSON KILL.
YOU WANT TO BE ABLE TO PROVE
MOTIVE.
IT HELPS EXPLAIN THE CASE TO THE
JURY, BUT YOU DON'T HAVE TO.
I THINK IT IS WORTH NOTING THAT
THE COMPLAINT DOES SUGGEST THE
POTENTIAL MOTIVE HERE.
THEY TALK ABOUT THE FACT AND
GARY ELUDED TO THIS THAT 12
DIFFERENT TIMES THIS INDIVIDUAL
WENT BY THAT HOUSE.
AS GARY SAID, IT IS NOT
SOMETHING YOU WOULD PASS BY.
THERE COULD BE A SUGGESTION HERE
THERE WAS SOME SORT OF STALKING
OR OBSESSIVE TYPE OF MOTIVE.
>> IT DOES SEEM AS THOUGH BRYAN
KOHBERGER WAS AT THE SCENE OF
THE KILLINGS.
WHAT IS STOPPING HIS DEFENSE
TEAM FROM JUST SAYING, OKAY, HE
WAS THERE BUT HE DIDN'T KILL
ANYBODY.
I MEAN I SUPPOSE THEY COULD TRY
THAT SORT OF DEFENSE.
WHO HAS THE BURDEN OF PROOF?
>> SO THE PROSECUTOR ALWAYS
BEARS THE BURDEN OF PROOF, OF
PROVING HIS CASE BEYOND A
REASONABLE DOUBT.
THAT'S THE HIGHEST STANDARD IN
OUR SYSTEM.
I DO EXPECT THAT THAT MAY WELL
BE A DEFENSE.
SURE, THEY CAN PROVE HE'S THERE,
BUT CAN THEY PROVE HE DID THE
KILLING.
I THINK THE PROSECUTORS WILL
COME BACK WITH, FIRST OF ALL, HE
DOESN'T KNOW ANY OF THESE
PEOPLE.
HE HAS NO REASON TO BE THERE.
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANY
EVIDENCE ANYONE ELSE WAS THERE.
HERE IS WHERE I THINK THE
EVIDENCE THAT THIS INDIVIDUAL
TRIED TO COVER UP HIS TRACKS
AFTER THE FACT BECOMES SO
IMPORTANT.
OUR JOHN MILLER, OUR COLLEAGUE,
HAS REPORTED THAT THE POLICE
WATCHED HIM.
HE WENT TO HIS PARENTS' HOUSE IN
PENNSYLVANIA.
THEY WATCHED HIM CLEANING HIS
CAR INSIDE AND OUT.
THEY WATCHED HIM WEARING
SURGICAL GLOVES.
THEY WATCHED HIM TAKE HIS
GARBAGE OUT AT 4:00 A.M. AND PUT
IT NOT IN HIS OWN PARENTS'
GARBAGE CANS BUT IN A NEIGHBOR'S
GARBAGE CANS.
I THINK THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
AND I THINK THAT'S REALLY
POWERFUL WITH A JURY.
>> AND KOHBERGER IS CHARGED WITH
FOUR COUNTS OF MURDER IN THE
FIRST DEGREE.
IS THAT AIMING TOO HIGH DO YOU
THINK FOR THE PROSECUTORS?
>> NO, I THINK THAT'S EXACTLY
APPROPRIATE HERE.
WHAT MAKES THIS A FIRST DEGREE
MURDER UNDER IDAHO LAW IS THAT
IT WAS PREMEDITATED, THAT IT WAS
PLANNED.
IT WASN'T SOMETHING THAT
HAPPENED ON THE SPUR OF THE
MOMENT IN A FIGHT,
SPONTANEOUSLY, UNEXPECTEDLY.
SO I DO THINK IT IS APPROPRIATE
THAT THESE PRO